我們跟大家解釋一下
這個內外盤的買賣
對我們的投資可以怎麼樣來幫忙
來幫助加分
因為一般賞戶
他沒有說專業的訓練
所以你發現他在掛架的時候
因為他平常是在幫人家上課的
今天把大家當新手
好好教一下
譬如說我們在這個地方
尾賣的這個地方
請問它是什麼
它是內盤
尾賣的這個地方是外盤
所以當我建議
有當國標飛賣不可
請問一定要把它賣掉
你會往內盤丟還是往外盤丟
你會往這個地方
往內盤丟
反過來右檔股票非常看好它
一定會漲
所以你會往拿兵買
你有外盤吃價
所以是內外盤基本的觀念
可是右檔市長戶沒有啊
你右檔股票非賣不可
應該往這邊賣嘛 對不對
可是他這樣他掛高賣
最好掛什麼
大漲賣 掛漲停板賣
他永遠賣不掉
真正走落想賣賣不掉
非賣不可 你要看願意出什麼價
可是你看到漲一個強勢股想買
好貴喔 買不下去 我掛第一買
下個往下越掛越好
最好掛第一買買到之後馬上長上去
想太多了
所以有些牆事骨買不到
自己落事骨想要出也出不掉
所以他的邏輯完全是錯的
所以應該怎麼做好呢
怎麼做啊 我想這個慶榮
可以幫忙解釋一下
你要摳奧喔 摳奧一下來
一般來講如果內盤的
因為每天其實他的成交
其實都會看到外盤的比
重比較高
還是成交在內盤價比這種比較高
這不對投資人來講有意義嗎
因為有可能是做出來的
有可能是做出來的
所以我們先來講正常的狀態
正常的狀態的話
如果是內盤價
如果是比例比較高的話
那就代表
阿Sir 代表什麼
代表市長上的人
用比較低的價格去拋售
成交內盤比較多
但是比較低的價格拋售
所以未來的股價
就會有比較大的下跌的壓力
那反之如果外盤價比例比較高
就代表大家想要去追價
未來想會上升的比機率就會更高
那這是正常的狀態
那有些時候會出現不正常的狀態
那不正常的狀態的時候
你就要搭配一些關係來看
比如說如果是外盤大於內盤
但是股價不漲反跌
那就是小心可能是大於要出貨了
喔 好
因為外盤的時候
代表說大家比較想要去追加賣盤
力道比較強
但股價竟然沒有漲啊
還跌
代表這個外盤是有人在做造假
有時候我們看到買賣價
比如說你現在看賣盤
可能14張 然後賣盤200張
那你覺得如果要賣的人
他還會在乎
他當然就是馬上就流
他為什麼要掛在那邊
可是他價格竟然沒有動
那其實你會發現
過一下子整個就突破
然後就往上拉
有時候是人家故意掛出來
要吸引你
想說有200張在那邊賣
我要趕快把我的股票賣出去
不然那個200張殺出來
價格會跌
結果後來根本沒有疊
對 其實現在偷偷在吃貨嘛
對 這是第一個嘛
那第二個就是
外盤如果小於內盤
然後如果骨架不疊反生
那就可能注意大戶在吃貨了
嗯
OK
這樣大家分手嗎
在了解如果出現了
骨架不正常的反應的時候
也許常常就是有不同的思維模式